irresistible cinnamon eggy bread with
quick stewed apples
I've never forgotten I think I was about
six years of age when mum brought this
huge tray of eggy bread to the table and
it was like wow man we've died and gone
to heaven start off with a slightly
stale bread four five day old loaf left
over if it's a fresh bread then it
absorbs too much of the egg so therefore
it gets soggy you never get it fried and
Crisp And if you're not going to use for
breadcrumbs eggy bread is a must
France they call it pan Perdue the Lost
loaf
now thank you bread is great on its own
but serving it with stewed apples is
delicious so the secret here
keep the skins on a lot of flavor in the
skin and also it stops the Apple from
breaking down too quickly they get these
nice chunks as opposed to sort of Apple
puree
[Music]
get your pan nice and hot and sprinkle a
couple of tablespoons of sugar
take the sugar down to a light caramel
it's quite incredible how cheap it is to
make this and yet it was so filling
if you haven't got apples this recipe
will work pretty much with any fruit
you've got in
[Music]
it's a mix a pear and an apple a banana
and a pineapple just chew it lightly
tossing the caramel get a little knob of
butter
that makes a nice toffee Apple flavor
really simple
now
you can see what's happening the apples
are caramelizing but they're staying
intact because the skins on the apple
and the caramel is turned into this nice
rich butterscotch sauce
once you've glazed all the apples a
couple of tablespoons of water in there
bring that to the ball and let that cook
out now the eggs
three whole eggs
whisk up the eggs
add about four tablespoons of milk you
want the egg thick and Rich and then
lightly sprinkle in a couple of
tablespoons of sugar that sweetens up
the mixture and when you start frying
the bread
caramelizes it usually a teaspoon of
powdered cinnamon that gives the bread
that really nice spicy deliciousness
apples are glazing beautifully
and put them on a low heat and get a pan
on now for the bread
spoon of oil and stops the butter from
burning butter in
so that starts frothing get your bread
in it's gonna be pretty quick now now
you don't leave the bread soak it
train
and in the pan
foreign
has browned flip it over
90 seconds each side that butter gives
that nice golden brown color of the egg
beautiful
[Music]
absolutely beautiful
it's quite remarkable isn't it a couple
of eggs splash of milk leftover apples
and all of a sudden you've got this
stunning breakfast
[Music]
now my apples they've all glazed
beautifully
get a nice spoon of that amazing juice
and drizzle that over
wow if my mum saw me doing this she'd
kill me you're getting all Posh again
none of them I'm using a touch of ice
sugar to make it look stunning
not for me takes me back to when I was
six years of age
and I thought
I just won the lottery that is
incredible
thank you Brad
[Music]
you won't get more breakfast for your
buck my mum's incredibly delicious
cinnamon eggy bread with quick stewed
apples
[Music]
My ultimate comfort food dinner is a
stunning sausage Hot Pot which will
serve with a gorgeous potato and
beetroot gratin
now I love Hot Pot you love Hot Pot
and you love sausages right yeah what'd
you enjoy most about sausages
I just love having them with the baked
beans sometimes with baked beans
sometimes these are
button mushrooms okay you just take them
into there like that
and keep them all and cut them into
quarters please now the important thing
about cooking sausages is they need a
bit of color right no color no flavor
exactly get the pan nice and hot how was
school today school was good thanks we
got to go out and make snowmen sausages
in
okay butter mushrooms in there please my
Danny
see
now
want you to watch your fingers but you
know how to slice onions right
definitely
now
sausages
I get in lots of color because this is
going to cook slowly
and it's sort of Daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one
nannies to make for me yeah once you've
got the color on them
and check them out
to rest okay
a little butter okay into the pan
stuff
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so they'll go down by half
give that a little fry okay salt in
I want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little buds
that will get the onions
pack the flavor this feel nice smells
nice mushrooms in give them a nice
little stir did you like to help me make
your hot pot when she made them for you
I used to always help now make the hot
pot always now my mum would never have
used this but A's balsamic vinegar
brings out the flavor of the onions
right now look at her onions look
beautiful caramelized the vinegar has
given that nice sort of gloss I'm gonna
put my sausages back in here now from
there
some red wine
red wine in
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is going to release all that flavor
inside as well look at the color of that
and it's still not cooked yet up to the
ball really important to boil it here
because it won't boil in the oven 170 in
the oven literally
18 to 20 minutes and she goes nice
to go with my hot pot Rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and I'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
start by gently heating double cream
[Music]
then peel and thinly sliced potatoes and
cook beetroot
foreign
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and beetroot
seasoning in between
[Music]
end with a neat layer of potatoes and
pour the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beetroot gratin are bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the Apple compod what we need to
do first is to get these peeled and
sliced
I got my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
huh
isn't it thanks for the warning
blew my head off they're incredibly
acidic okay and you need to cook them
those wonderful red apples you've got
are called Bray Burns what other apples
you know cream ones what are they called
um
another word for your nan
Grandma's no
red no Pink Lady apple no Granny Smith
Granny Smith apple that's right what
we're gonna do is cook the cooking
apples and
the eating apples together I love the
combination of the tartness from the
Bramley cooking apple with the sweetness
of the Brae bun get the pan nice and hot
sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger and three little cinnamon sticks
I want you to remember that because
we're going to look for them okay
because once we use them and they've
worked their magic I need to pull them
out see all the sugar dissolving
now we just let that go a little bit
darker
okay and then
quick doesn't it
give that a nice
little toss
okay a nice golden color cinnamon in
ginger in so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cook until the apples soften then
take off the heat
let me go into there what's that coming
out Dan so that is a little bit of the
puree I'll show you we'll do that in a
minute how many Ginger
four four Ginger
three cinnamon three cinnamon out with a
cinnamon
and take
a spoon
of apples
it smells so nice how nice is that look
see the color of the apples let's put
these in the fridge to get nice and cold
that's the Comfort sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to Crown the top you
separate the egg whites into there for
Daddy
right egg whites are in I think it's
separate off your good eye
[Music]
and I'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
should go
[Music]
there's your place now let's see if
you've got a really nice stiff Pig so
you lift them up
and that is what I call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad next in a
separate Bowl whip double cream until
stiff
nice and slowly
foreign
whips so much quicker
we're gonna put some delicious lemon
zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compote puree
and you mix that in nice and carefully
it says like this apple
butterscotch now to make the cream even
lighter fold in those whisked egg whites
and sugar egg whites
into the cream
just nicely fold that in
so we bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses yep good girl
hmm silly we're on for a treat open up
the Piping Bag Now do just the end now
you could spoon this in but I want to
just give a nice little lift it also
gives it a nice pattern lemon on top
fridge the beetroot and potato gratin is
that lovely that's lovely sausages
finished with a flat leaf parsley
look at those two beauties it doesn't
get any more comforting than that does
it for one of the best hot pots
ever Tilly that looks amazing
well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by Apple comp art